Let's go and extend the Python code appropriately
such that we now have three states instead of just two.
So we're introducing a variable named quote, which initially is false,
because in the beginning they were non-tag mode.
And now, we simply check for double quote or a single quote,
and if we see any of these, the codes variable gets inverted.
And now, if quote is set, then the HTML markup characters should have no effect.
So we make sure that the HTML markup characters only have effect if quote is set.
Finally, we need to make sure that quotes only have a special meaning within tags,
so we make this endtag instead.
We still have our example down here, which previously failed, because of output quote foo.
Let us see where this output now is properly handled and we click on run.
The output is foo.
All the HTML markup--you can read this complex combination of quotes
and end of markup characters is now properly removed--great.